[Music]
i like this one
[Music]
whenever you're down
[Music]
there is
[Music]
[Music]
there is a
light and that yeah that is uh
there is a light
we played it a month ago
on there right around easter
on that uh belated bunny episode we
played that there is a light
by stone keepers
featuring david manway menu manuei
manuei
manuei
something
um
yeah look hey hey hey hey it's uh
middle of may
and um a lot going on in the world
it's springtime baby you know you could
hear the bees in the distance they're
out there
they out there honey hunting them bees
baby you can hear them
you can hear that buzz baby
you can hear just mother nature just
trying to just
just trying to skeet all over the place
you know it just
it's pretty romantic actually if you
fall asleep put your ear by the window
before you go to bed
you can hear them be i mean you just the
bees are up at night
they just everything's just trying to
bloom and bust and
and just go on dates and just everything
i mean it is damn senior prom for mother
nature right now baby we are in the
midst
of spring
yeah and i just got back from
maui i went on a small vacation for
myself
uh to get just get my
just
let my credentials get in order just let
the
just to let the sand settle
inside of me a little bit and um
and it felt good you know i if you've
never been to maui you got to go there
i mean it's a lot of honeymooners so
that was
you know there's a lot of people holding
hands and then some sometimes everybody
was holding hands so much i found i
would just
put one of my hands out and then just
hold just hold it with the other hand
just so i didn't feel out of place
sometimes and so
you know i kind of walked around like a
lot of uh
you know you know a lot of religious
guys will do that too they'll shake your
hand they put the other hand on top of
it
they make that little hand uh
hand
hand sandwich kind of about you know
just thank you for coming you know
people do that a lot of times at
funerals
they put they shake the hand they put
the other hand on the double there you
go
just a little hand threesome right there
just thank you for coming
you know people will do that when they
just double hand you
the first time it ever happens usually
is at a church there's somebody somebody
will double hand you like damn what hat
you know
especially i remember being young and
just learning to shake hands you didn't
know exactly
how did you know sometimes i put my hand
in backwards and just [ __ ] just
you know i put my thumb facing down and
whoever was shaking your hand didn't
know what the hell to do you know the
guy just sometimes he just
loses just he'd come out the damn closet
he didn't even know what was happening
you know just
because if you sh if you put your hand
out and just the thumb is it just
blows somebody's mind in a handshake
it's really
you can just really
somebody who's just
been going through life very organized
shaking hands
you hit them with that upside down
handshake and they just [ __ ] they
can't handle it you know the damn
you know they'll [ __ ] get a divorce
they don't they just don't know what's
going on um
and then you when you're when you're
growing up handshaking is such a
man i remember when they first
somebody's like well shake their hand
they you know your mom tells you shake
their hand
and you don't you know something you put
your hand out that you don't know at
first and then
and then one time my dad introduced me
to somebody and the guy shook my hand so
hard
and i remember thinking all right
[ __ ]
all right boy
[ __ ] punch your little kid in the
neck when i see him i just remember just
thinking i'ma you know i'm gonna get
these [ __ ] back
this [ __ ] ain't over i remember that the
guy my dad introduced me to the guy and
the guy just shook my my hand so hard
and i just remember thinking all right
[ __ ] this [ __ ] ain't over
and i had just you know
just a lot you know so much happens in a
handshake
especially when you're learning the
ropes of handshaking
it's a crazy time for a
young fella or young woman
so then when you shake somebody's hand
and they do the dub when they
they do this regular handshake and then
they put their hand on top of you on the
back of your hand
and they're just running a train on your
hand with their hands it's just
it's too much you're like what i didn't
know we could do that
i thought you could only do one just the
rules keep changing you know you're like
i thought we could only do one hand and
this dude's tagging in his partner
this dang you know this guy's you know
the steiner brothers every i thought you
know it was just a
um
a cage match and he's running a damn
royal rumble on my hands
it just uh
i remember this just the slippery slopes
of shaking hands
and of learning what it was all like
that was kind of interesting to me
and then i dated a gal for a while that
would do a hard handshake and i'm like i
didn't want to introduce her to people
because i knew she'd just be rattling
them just you know just damn
just you know testing their joints every
time you freaking
introduced her to somebody she would
just test their joints it felt like
just uh
that was tough jesus i remember that
that was tough
um
anyway
what's going on i'll get into it i went
over to um to maui hawaii to have a
vacation for myself
and um
and man it just it's so nice and we got
some beautiful calls that came in we'll
get into a little bit of the news
and uh
and yeah just
living the day baby
living
and just letting the lord just hold my
ass
um i want to let you know these tour
dates this week actually
wednesday i'll be in albuquerque um
new mexico thursday i'll be in midland
midland texas
uh friday may 20th i'll be in lubbock
texas
and then uh may 21st i'll be in dallas
texas the following
beginning of june 2nd savannah georgia
if you have friends over there tell them
to come through
augusta georgia june 3rd montgomery
alabama june 4 and columbus ga june 5.
then i'll be in florida june 23rd
through the 26th hollywood florida
fort myers
daytona beach
and lakeland florida and that's all in
june
go to theovonne.com
t-o-u-r
to get those tickets go through those
links
don't let them get you on that secondary
market
you know those secondary tickets you
they might have fentanyl in them
you don't know
you don't know what's in them
um
[Music]
so we just want you to get that
firsthand uh at the you know uh fair
price tickets
what else oh
yeah i went over to we had some great
shows out in tulsa oklahoma
and man i just want to thank everybody
that came through there that place had
been
that it had been sold out for months
they said and uh
the staff there was all excited and
um
[Music]
yeah i got into town over there i was
feeling a little rattled
so i went and hit an aaa meeting right
before the show
over there off of lewis drive over there
they got a spot over there i think the
unanimity club or something deal i went
over there
with my shady ass handshake and just
you know that hand it's just if somebody
teaches you wrong how to hand you just
you know
it just is interesting how
somebody that's the first thing they
teach you you know
it's just uh
you know it's just interesting um
yeah just a beautiful time over there in
um
in tulsa
and the staff they said you know that
that show had been sold out for months
and uh it was
just a lot of good people i met three
guys named tyler in the lobby
in a row
i went down before the show to get me a
little burger or something
you know a little while i didn't know
what i wanted
and that's the word the worst thing to
do is wander downstairs into a casino
not sure what you want
because you could end up with anything
son you could end up with a little bit
of uh
hamburger you could end up with a damn
uh debt
you could end up with a hooker
you could end up with uh
gay men chasing you men hookers
so
i think
that has to be a new rule for me is but
when i leave a hotel room to have a plan
in a casino
but yeah i went down there and met three
tylers in a row i said well damn
too bad this you know
that it's not a human slot machine where
you get three tilers and you win
something because i met three tylers in
a row boom boom boom taller taller
taller
hey my name's taller hey i'm taller
guess what
dollar
so it was just triple tilers man right
out the gate over there and uh
yeah i wish i'd gotten to meet everybody
that came out we stayed after and met
i've met met some people that milled
around in the lobby and uh i'm grateful
for that
um
and then we went on oh los angeles
dude that was crazy uh
that was that was crazy
i mean the crowds were so um
it was during the netflix is a joke
festival
and netflix didn't do [ __ ] for us so i
want to thank everybody that came out
and supported uh netflix did all the
advertising for so many other acts
and they didn't give us [ __ ]
and uh
and our crowd came out
and showed love man so thank you guys
um
that meant a lot to me
and those shows damn just you know
they had a dude in there uh
who kept trying to show me his tattoo
during the show this guy had a tattoo on
his back
of angel wings
and the whole time he's trying to show
me the tattoo and i'm just thinking
finally i kind of see what he's saying
and i'm like
all of this and i don't give a [ __ ] bruh
you know what i'm saying like that was a
like i'm glad you got it but damn dude
you know like
you don't have to this is the this is in
the time and place for all this dude the
guy kept trying he kept like kind of
giving these hand motions and pulling
his shirt i didn't know what he was
doing i don't know if he was doing
laundry i didn't know what the guy was
doing
but none of it made any sense and then
finally
his buddy this little guy with him who
looked like he had um
the buddy looked like somebody had
smoked had smoked him it looked like
somebody had taken his friend and put
him in a pipe and took a couple hits off
him
you know the dude just looked a little
crisp a little crisped out
uh
and i think he even had like kind of
burn marks not like on his skin but it's
on his clothes like somebody had um
tried to you know do like a maybe small
campfire or something
like right next to him like he had that
kind of vibe you know but anyway that
guy finally pulled up his buddy shirt
and he's pointing it like i don't
i don't and that's when i realized i
don't give a [ __ ] about that
like there's a lot of things i do want
to care about but
seeing a grown man's angel wing tats is
not that is nowhere on my list of uh
things that i really want to care about
but yeah thank you to everybody that
came out man and showed love and um
those those shows were nuts
they were just
people were cheering so much it was like
hard to even pay attention i didn't
there were times where i turned around
and looked behind me i thought there was
something like there was a football game
going on behind me
it was just it was live man it was
really live
um
what else occurred
oh i'll tell you about this man so
oh i went over to maui
and if you haven't been to maui then
you gotta do it
you know one of the nice things is the
place shuts down early so nine o'clock
you're in bed everybody's in bed
ever you can feel the everybody is in
bed
during every bed you can hear like
every bed is just eaten you know because
somebody filled that [ __ ] up
every bed in the joint
has got some
something in its tummy dude something
human just lodged right in the middle of
it
and it just feels uh there's a huge
relaxation to it
um
oh and then this this happened um
you know sometimes like
you run you run into guys uh
and it's great but sometimes when you're
in a hotel you're or any place you're
gonna be for a long time
you could run into the guy countless
times you know repetitionally
and so this fell i'm at this hotel the
second day and this guy
says what's up
he's uh
he's a nice guy being real friendly
and
um
and then finally he goes hey man
the conversation had kind of gotten
where there wasn't much left to say
which is okay that's when everybody kind
of goes their separate ways
and he goes hey man i'm going to give
you uh
i'm going to give you six guesses what
my name is and i'm like oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
because i don't want to do that
i don't want that man
i'm i don't want that
you know i don't want
i want no guesses how many
how much what names the man is
but
you know i guess there
there's a part of me that likes games i
guess so i said
alex
and uh
and he goes no but that's close
and he goes i'll give you three extra
guesses and i'm like oh [ __ ] dude
i don't want that
i don't want that man
i don't want that extra guesses
i don't so now i have nine guesses minus
one now i have eight guesses what this
guy's name is and i don't want no
guesses
um so anyway he goes and you don't have
to guess again right now i'll see you
around the way right because he worked
at the place
so dude i kept i ran into this guy
i ran into this guy uh
i mean i ran into this guy 30 more times
over the week
and it was just a nightmare and finally
you know i guess like i did like two
other guesses because there was you know
one day i had already done my wordle or
whatever and so i was like i need a game
to play and he [ __ ] wandered up and
he always wandered up
i mean he would wander up on a damn wind
you know i mean somebody would cough a
few feet away and he'd
he'd wander right up out of their damn
esophagus this dude wandered up you know
he was the kind of guy that wandered up
so finally i'm trying to guess and uh
i'm like tyler is it tyler um the guy
tells me that his name is
galaxy
and that's why alex was close
and at that point i knew it was time to
leave man it was time to leave bro
that's when
that's when it's time to go
so um
what else happened there beautiful place
if you've never been to maui you need to
go
um
and you need to also they have a place
there mama's fish house
over there
up near paella or paella
you roll up there and
do you gotta know like there was no
reservation so i called a few times
there's no reservation
and then so i was up there anyway
looking for a swimming hole
where i picked up a hitchhiker last time
i was there i pick up a hitchhiker and
uh
because i love hitchhikers baby now
that's a game that's a game show you
want to do a game show pick up a
hitchhiker
and see what god
wants for you
um
because that's the devil's roshambo baby
hitchhikers hello
yeah man
[Music]
so anyway man uh
yeah what was i talking about
[Music]
jeremy what was i talking about do you
know
like before maui yeah
oh no
yeah i don't know when i was talking
about anything but um
oh
i'll tell you this man uh i got it
thanks jay
we got jeremy in here helping out today
um
[Music]
grateful that he's here uh
oh a man died bro
a man died um
so i'm at breakfast right
i'm at breakfast one morning and
and uh
and the place i'm staying at man i
treated myself the place i'm staying was
pretty nice dude they had like a
concierge breakfast so you go down there
you know and it's [ __ ]
you know i don't know who the concierge
was but i'll tell you this his wife can
cook i'll say that because they had it
bro they had it
and they got hawaii you know who it is
man they got a lot of beautiful i mean
it's asia but it's more like uh
it's like those pineapple asians baby
you know what i'm saying and they know
their smile first over there their smile
first baby
and uh just beautiful culture god
beautiful culture man and they're also
the native americans of the island
people don't realize that
hawaiian people they're like the indian
they're the sun they're like the um
they're really they're those saltwater
indians baby they're over there there's
those uh
you know
those uh
volcano they're the volcano um
forefathers
i mean those people are over there
anybody that can
do sex on the side of a volcano
bro
that is
i've done drugs and i've tried to get
erect on uh when i was you know on half
an eight ball right
which is impossible dude
i remember one time uh
like just
i've done some
tough things to try to get erect but i
uh
was talking about oh but anybody that's
brave enough to
do
do some serious
fornicating on the side of a
volcano bruh
hats off to those people son
hats off son
so yeah shout out to beautiful hawaiians
bro they that right there they should
win an award or whatever you know if the
president don't give out that award
you know the vulcan cuz also you're
you're doing sex on a damn uh
it you're on a damn gradient
against lava it's i mean
that's
that's
that they deserve an award
um but oh at breakfast a guy died bro
a guy
oh
i can't even believe that that laugh
just came out of me and that was that's
satan bro
um but a guy died at breakfast a guy met
his maker and i don't know what he was
having
i didn't get a look at his plate
but um
my friend had joined me we're sitting
over there and we are um
you know she was doing a crossword or
doing whatever brought her some joy and
there's a rambunction in the corner
and i didn't know what it was i thought
maybe it was one of those uh
charlos and uh
you know charles and charlie's or
whatever where they shake the guy's neck
and they put the liquor in his face and
they shake your stepdad's neck or
whatever until he can't even breathe or
something
and then they call it you know they're
like uh hey there you go fatty you know
they say stuff like that to them but
they put the licker in his mouth and
they got the whistle and [ __ ]
and then they you know put take a
picture whatever they put sell you like
a magnet or whatever i thought it was
that kind of thing because there's like
a big rambunction
but then i look over and they're yelling
somebody's yelling 9-1-1 and i'm like
that is
that's old-fashioned that doesn't make
any sense really but um
but then other people realize oh call
9-1-1 so because some guy's just yelling
9-1-1 9-1-1 i'm like oh man
i don't know i guess that's i mean it's
definitely how it works but it's a just
an older way of doing it
so anyway people started calling 9-1-1
and then
they just asked that anybody be a doctor
here
and dude when you're sitting there as a
man you're like damn you realize you
have
no skills bro
that's what i realized anyway i'm like
damn they somebody there
they had the man on the ground and
i mean this brave guy came over
and uh
and he's suddenly the bravest dude in
the room because he knew skills
to do cpr
so he's doing it there's a nurse lady
there she's doing it
and they're just helping and then the
rest of us are just
sitting there and i just felt like oh
man
i don't
have any
life-saving skills
um
and there's something about that it hits
you you're like damn all the things i've
learned
and i haven't learned this skill i
haven't learned a real
and the worst part i'll hear is the
worst part
so they're over there they say they got
they're bringing him back and he goes
back to the other side i mean he's just
playing red rover with the devil over
there you know or with the lord i don't
know his backstory
but that guy is just there like you know
send you know andy or whatever you know
red rover you know sin and and they're
just he's going back he's in and out and
in and out and they're like we're losing
and we're gaining and we're losing and
we're gaining them and um
and i didn't know what to do dude and
then this is the saddest part i just
started eating again
and i'm like oh my god am i the kind of
guy that just eats when somebody's dying
oh man and so that kind of broke my
heart i'm like and i remember just like
i cut into this sausage patty
and i'm like there's no way you're gonna
eat right now right
because it was like it was obvious there
was like a group of people that had go
on over to help and if you can't help
you got to stay out the way you can't be
over there just you know lighting
candles or like
you know somebody was there with his
wife so everything you know all the
corners were kind of covered
and i said a few prayers
but then
i just started eating this sausage patty
dude
and it [ __ ] honestly man it broke my
heart
i'm like do i
i don't know it just there was something
about it it was just a lot man i'm like
oh
and i had one bite i'm like there's no
way i have another bite because you can
hear them doing the cpr
and then i had another
bite and i'm like oh my god bro
just stop eating
just stop eating if there's any time
where god is looking down at the earth
to see what's happening
it's when somebody's transporting
through
you know the portal between life and
death is open here
and this guy is about to freaking andy
doofrain his way up there
and i'm sitting there
eating bro oh
it was so bad man
oh it just felt weird so
so that was that bro
i want to let you know that uh your
brain gets bad sometimes if you don't
exercise
and people say well that's not backed by
science i'll tell you what it is back by
science and what's my proof i've done
that and i've lived that and you know it
so who are we lying to who we talking
about
but what i want to tell you is having a
routine helps as well
and nothing helps that more than fit
bod fitbod's innovative algorithm
creates a dynamic fitness plan based on
your personal goals equipment and
fitness level that's right plus it
learns with each workout so you're
always set up for your next session to
be your best one
that's right fit bod
the path to being your best looks
different for everyone that's why
they've created a program
that tracks your muscle recovery
balancing your workout plan with a
variety of exercises to avoid
overworking certain muscles
visualize your usage recovery
achievements and workout streaks right
in the fitbod app
yep their new app interface is easy to
use and has a brand new hd video
tutorial to make learning new
experiences a breeze it works with apple
watch
wear os smart watch and apps like apple
health fitbit and strava
and right now you can get 25 off your
subscription or try out the app for free
when you sign up now at fitbod.me-theo
that's f-i-t-b-o-d dot m-e-t-h-e-o
that's 25 off your subscription at fit
dot me slash theo attention listeners
you're ready to be blown away wow wow
wow
fire
you asked for it and manscape listened
they just relaunched the ultra smooth
package it's back baby your new favorite
tool and complement
to the lawnmower 4.0
keeps your boys your nuts your body your
uvula or whatever smooth while looking
and feeling its best that's right
this specialized groin shaving kit is
here to help you buff
protect and shave your most sensitive
areas
crop that bush daddy crop that bush crap
that bush
get 20 off in free shipping at
manscape.com with the code t-h-e-o
yep
grab your handy lawnmower 4.0 and give
them boys a classic trim
dot dial them up get them nice looking
get them ready for the beach or for the
mountains
uh
take out the manscaped ultra smooth
package to make your package perfect for
summer get 20 off and free shipping
with code theo at manscaped that's 20
off
and free shipping with the code t-h-e-o
at manscaped.com
smooth out your fellas with the
re-launched ultra-smooth package from
the fellas at manscape your balls will
thank you
but man i just love mount i love the
people i love the energy
you know
just the kindness of the local hawaiian
people the culture
you know it really does make you look
back and wonder if like
people taking over lands and like
colonize it just what it all what it did
to the nature of everything
how much it disoriented that uh
the heartbeat the original heartbeat of
nature
and how much it all got rattled off you
know
and how much it got distorted and
reverbed and just
you know
unequalized and all of that whatever i
don't know all the audio terms but
it makes you wonder
you know uh and i'm not this
you know i'm not
saying nothing bad if you know
for anybody that's i mean whatever
happened in the past happened but
it does when you you know when you're in
a place like hawaii dog or mama or ma
maui
you don't it's like
you know you're just so close to nature
it's like you're just [ __ ]
it's like you're in a damn hammock and
each end of the hammock is one of
nature's nuts bruh and you're just right
there
god you feel like a damn dinosaur could
come and clean your ass with his paw
that's maui man you right there
right there baby
and they got shave ice and everybody's
just you know
somebody be dying and they're just like
hey
surf's up you know just like you're
dying like doesn't matter almost i'm out
of here you know
so anyway beautiful vibe over there and
um
and yeah that's what was going on and uh
in maui i was grateful to be over there
didn't do any shows
um
but thoroughly enjoyed myself and uh
yeah and just grateful people that came
out uh to the shows that we did have in
uh
in tulsa and we we popped in oklahoma
city just for a short one over there
um
and then um
the one in los angeles
but let's get into the news man we got
some beautiful calls that came in from
you guys and let's get into the news
what do you got over there brother
see we got the story a couple robbed of
19 000 in watches suspect fleas and a
rolls royce this happened in los angeles
there you go just say where in los
angeles west hollywood it looks like
hollywood baby well one of the issues
that we deal with in hollywood uh is in
hollywood
you can't protect yourself anymore
if you have a weapon somebody make
writes an article oh this person had a
weapon you know and you're like oh
anybody trying to defend themselves or
take care of themselves in hollywood
is looked down upon oh you got a frying
pan oh you got oh no that's an egg
weapon
that's a what are you doing to eggs are
you mistreating eggs in the morning
like mitch it's a frying pan
everything in this city you can't have
nothing
everything in hollywood you can't have
nothing they'll come oh you oh you got a
strong chin
you better check that at the airport
i had a black friend i brought a black
friend somewhere the other day they're
like do you have a permit for that guy i
said
that's andre bro what do you what
you can't have everything is dangerous
here
everything is dangerous man hollywood i
just never met a place like that
so if the if rich people are starting to
pop off on rich people
i'll look i'll buy a front row i'll
watch that on zoom
that's where i'm at with it i it's about
time man
i'm tired of poor people having to do
all the fighting
uh
i'm ready so if i the rich versus the
rich baby
let's go i'm here for that
what else do we have here uh
jer what else we got
fired arby's manager admits to urinating
at least twice in milkshake mix police
say
this took place in vancouver washington
okay and look at let's be we knew this
was happening
we there's nobody who lays their head
down at night
on any decent pillow
and says
honestly to themselves that
rvs
employees are not
urinating in the
beverages
there's no if you're honest with
yourself you laid it later close your
eyes right now and ask yourself
are arby's employees
urinating in the beverages and you your
heart will tell you yeah
because that's where we are
that's where and that honestly that's
where we've always been
and the the crazy part is
this kind of goes into that moment when
when an officer is like how many beers
have you had and you always just say two
don't say you've had more than two bro
you've had more than two
you know you left your kid in the car
one day while you were at cvs you've had
more than two beers
but that's what it is like hey mr arby's
manager sir how many times have you
urinated in the what was it
milkshake mix oh damn boy
yes sir how many times have you urinated
in the milkshake mix boy
and uh oh just twos two i've only had
two sir yeah
we we know you have more boy
look i charge extra and half of these
countries and [ __ ] they pay
rich people are drinking piss man don't
if you get bring them some piss from
them in guatemala or somewhere
foreign piss they'll sip it
dude at some of these high dollar
political functions they're over there
somebody's sommeliering off that
freaking uh that nut sniffer dog you
know what i'm saying
off that that that that penis wine baby
piss urine
so you know rich people they'll pay to
drink that [ __ ] that's the craziest
thing you go piss on a rich person they
get mad
but you piss in a jar and put it on a
fancy website and they'll buy it
that's insane isn't it
but yeah only twice in the milk there's
no way first of all how freaking good
does it have to feel
to piss into a if that thing's mixing up
in like a beautiful
and you just dousing it up
dude i remember throwing parties in
college and i would stand by the keg it
was in the kitchen in the corner i'd
stand there a couple hundred people at
the house because we did it good
at lsu at the commons baby gang gang son
we threw that [ __ ] dude
we threw somebody uh i remember i saw
this one chick belinda caught somebody
shot a potato gun right
and she was just looking for her keys
right about 70 yards away and that thing
caught her right in the neck boy
old top neck belinda son
damn baby she's never been the same bruh
she always she freaking can only look
one way when she crosses the street now
bruh she freaking that thing hooked her
um but anyway i hope she's doing good
and um
what are we talking about jeremy do you
remember it
uh we're talking about rp's maybe
oh rb's i see you saying that's a rv
that's a play on uh lettering and i love
it
yeah arby's dog if and look i worked at
a place oh yeah i i at my joint
at the party
we would fill cold beers up in a cup and
then every now and then we would do a
cup of urine pass it off across the
party
people didn't know
those people are doing well now they
have families that's god
you know and it's just
sometime life gives you lemonade
sometimes you get that little bit of uh
that piss at the arby's
and you knew that you knew you knew when
you walked in arby's there could be
pissing some
now that you definitely knew
you knew when you walked in the arby's
something i'm eating here probably gets
a little bit of that uh
that body licker in it you know what i'm
saying
that freaking scrotum gin baby you don't
talk about piss
and one more thing about orbeez is why
don't we have they need to put birth
control in the meat
why don't we that needs to be the next
thing that seemed like a perfect part of
the biden administration's uh
you know insurance medical deal
let's get birth control put into the
meat at arby's
i mean how many people would vote for
that everybody
what else we got there jerr uh they had
something with the breast milk i saw
see yeah we got a
utah mom selling almost 4 000 ounces of
breast milk as baby formula shortage
continues
this happened in uh utah alyssa chitty
has three freezers full of breast
milk and look that's where we are now
that's what i mean i'm telling you we
are getting to a place where you can't
count on these big companies anymore
they're all in lawsuits there's two they
don't know any what they're too
disconnected from the customer
so people going right off the bag now
you want that you uh we got piss
milkshakes we got fresh from i mean that
is just from uh firm to table baby right
there
if you you go people going door to door
shooting each other for uh breast milk
titty milk
men are trying to do you see a lot of
gay men trying to and they don't even
have kids they're just trying to uh
do ejaculate out of their
nipples just crazy it's getting weird
man
and ladies if you got that strong hooter
baby juice it out
juice it out son
especially utah you up at that high uh
elevation
so if you don't think you could sell
that high elevation freaking bee skeet
baby you know what i'm talking about
braz milk if you don't think you can
sell that for a decent dollar baby
then you're wrong honey if you're
sitting around just doing wordle all day
and you got them freaking uh
them freaking forest lumps baby them
damn [ __ ] leche furnace is just
brewing
you know women are always like i want to
open up a business but you got two
businesses right there
you got them freaking little sternum
corporations baby juice them out
juicing [ __ ]
i'll buy a hot gram of breast milk off
of somebody
and especially this is this is basic
white utah breast milk man
that's just a basic homogenized [ __ ] you
get into there you get a nice urban lady
out there she got those extra red blood
cells up in that
up in the milk
or you get a native american lady and
she got them you know what i'm saying
she got the forefathers in the milk you
know i'm saying you could really there's
definitely a way to um
what's that called uh uh
uh
it's a business thing um
there's definitely some uh
it means like going up do you know what
it is
uh
i don't i don't know trajectory
yeah i don't know no no that's not a
good guess uh
verticals they call it verticals
other ways you can make money on it but
yeah if you uh
yeah so there's way i mean there's
definitely some upsells in there you
know if you want that um
if you want that extra breast milk you
want that extra half ounce or you get
the daytime milk or you want that night
batch
now a lot of ladies don't realize if you
slang in breast milk on the internet
um
then you can also slang that night batch
you know
that uh if you want to sell that
nocturnal freaking uh that nocturnal
nipple beverage baby you know what i'm
talking about teddy milk uh
we had this kid in our neighborhood he
couldn't talk much but he could say
teddy milk
and we'd always be like what do you want
he'd be like kidding me
so anyway there's definitely a big
market out there for it because look
we're all becoming babies anyway
you know i'm an adult baby half my
friends are everybody i know
damn i would look if i hit a vending
machine and nobody was looking
i'd have me a little
gang maybe i don't think if we have any
other news in that do we
i think so praise god baby happy to be
alive today and i'm happy to get into
some of you guys's calls um
you know uh and i want to thank you guys
that come out and support me man on the
shows and just support me while watching
this show
um
[Music]
you know we had uh and just have been
supportive man it has been a tough i've
had a tough few years and i don't mean
that and i'm complaining i just haven't
been feeling great and uh you guys have
been there with me the whole time
and um
and yeah we just you know
we don't give up so i just want to say
thank you uh from the inside of my heart
baby you know what i'm saying
from damn just deep in my damn
just from the i mean just the real
you guys are the piss in my milkshake
so i love y'all
all right uh let's get into some calls
here um
let you know also that we have some new
gang gang hoodies uh and teas that are
available now at theovonstore.com
we've got the bobblehead that be head
baby if you need them
um you can get a hold of those
uh at
theovonstore.com thank you guys for
supporting
the podcast
thank you for our patreon supporters
and
yeah the hotline as always if
something's going on with you
and
uh the hotline is 985-664-9503
uh we got some
more help now working with the podcast
too so excited to uh
see how that works out and um just help
get our
just i feel like get the wheels back
going and keep things going well um
you know we got a important group here
of uh humans
and
uh we got to take care of uh
we got to take care of as much as we can
so
trying to lean into that more and uh
just grateful for you guys
um
let's take some calls here as always the
hotline is 985-664-9503
um
let's take one here here we go
hey theo got yourself a little covington
single mama drama
going on i can't believe you got the 985
my 985 touching your 985 right now
anyway
so
it's mother's day morning and i'm just
wondering what has a single mama got to
do
to get some good
some good loving all these men are
scared i mean for me personally i feel
like if you got a single mom coming for
you you know and like
putting the heat on you it's like you
already got half the equation figured
out like
you know she makes cute kids
you know she cooks you know she's
responsible you know she could keep your
offspring alive you know it's like what
what's the big
what's the big question here you know i
mean
yeah look i mean
i think
well let me hear more let me hear more
what's going on so you're trying to get
a little action
and you're from down there in covington
louisiana and i appreciate the beautiful
place there and i was conceived
somewhere over there near the chef the
river over there
and a lot of snakes around there and a
lot of uh
mosquitoes malaria was big when i was
young
and uh what else rabies
definitely down there in the bottom of
the
rabies belt let's hear more
why is everybody so you know terrified
of single moms maybe or maybe it's just
me maybe it could it could it could just
be me
but um there was somebody that i got a
little involved with
and he told me that he was this big theo
vaughn fan i was like oh i know that guy
from covington i don't know you but i
know that you're from covington me too
anyway
i was like well [ __ ] i'm gonna have to
call this [ __ ] and find out what
kind of messaging you giving these boys
because i mean
they're going out on the street saying
yeah diovan theovan big fan of single
moms single moms you know it's mother's
day eve i sent that booty call
it was just me and the magic wand this
morning man dang baby girl dang
dang
well also if you giving your body away
to that magic wand all the time then you
know i think a lot of men can sense that
a lot of men can sense sometimes if uh
if that garden has been hand dug or if
it's somebody been using a rotor on it
so that could be could be something i
don't know
now that's just i'm just gesticulating
or uh verb i'm just speaking
but now look if you if you met a guy he
said he's a theovonne fan he's uh
he's
texting you and stuff but he's not
coming over and putting it down
that sounds like a theovon fan you know
what i'm saying girl that's what we do
baby
we front it up but we don't back it up a
lot of times you know what i'm saying
especially look if he's if he he
probably
jerked off on the way over there if i'm
real honest with you dude i was in love
one time
with this girl and the problem was it
was 17 miles to get to her place and
this was out near covington and if you
went up north of covington
and 17 miles when you all horned out you
know when you really young and just full
of just bust you know i mean you just
nuts are just made out of damn just
god's dynamite baby you know what i'm
talking about semen
and when you are just just your nuts are
just rationed up to the top with that
sweet cream can i have some
i mean there's only you can't drive 17
miles without pulling over
and relieving yourself somewhere near a
damn mile marker
you know if you want to bet 40 dollars
that i haven't eat jacked on the back of
a damn mile marker and then you're gonna
lose your money
i'm gonna tell you that right now baby
you know what i'm saying 36.5
baby
um
so yeah look i'm just saying that could
that could have been it the guy is so
nervous he can't even handle all you
know
it's hard to drive when your body's full
of uh
the devil's fever
it's hard to drive that sickness across
town without pulling over to relieve it
so but yeah we appreciate the call there
lady and we hope somebody comes over and
gets that throbbing
and really just robs that throbbing
right out of your crotch for you
um
and yeah we'll get back to doing some
stuff for some single moms and stuff
soon uh
or single dads we've had some callers
talk about that and we're gonna get back
into some of that um
you know it can be hard to see the light
at the end of the tunnel that's a fact
man when you have high interest debt
that's a double fact man when you have
debt but you're also paying a high
interest rate it just hurts you it hurts
your dang hurt your dang nuts in your
back
saying goodbye to high interest credit
card debt is one of the first steps
towards financial independence
but the interest month after month can
feel like you're in a never-ending
hamster wheel that's where upstart comes
in
we've all been there seemingly out of
nowhere you get hit by an unexpected
expense or bill
when that happens it can feel like the
weight of the world is coming down
luckily upstart
helps
their personal powered loans can help
you pay down high interest debt
all done online with simple and easy to
understand payments
upstart has helped over 1.8 million
customers on their path to financial
freedom
upstart's model considers other factors
instead of your just your credit score
they consider income employment and
other information provided in your loan
application don't wait and check your
rate today at upstart.com
t-h-e-o
that's upstart.com
theo to check your rate today don't
forget to use our url to let them know
we sent you
and you want to make sure that you're
not paying high interest credit card
debt loan amounts will be determined
based on your credit income and other
certain information provided in your
loan application go to upstart.com
theo look after years of fine print
contracts and getting ripped off by big
wireless providers if we've learned
anything it's that there's always a
catch
so when i first heard that mint mobile
was
offering premium wireless at just 15
bucks a month i said what's the catch
well
mint mobile doesn't have a retail store
so they cut out that brook and mortal
you don't have to do that anymore
they're the first company to sell
wireless service only
online only that's right
for anyone who hates their phone bill
mint mobile offers premium wireless for
just 15 bucks a month switch to mint
mobile
get premium wireless
all plans come with unlimited talk and
text high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network
gives you the best rate whether you're
buying for one or a family
to get your new wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com
theo that's mint m-o-b-i-l-e.com
t-h-e-o cut your wireless bill of 15
bucks a month at mintmobile.com
all right let's take another call here
hey theo it's uh it's chris goss
i'm currently stationed at
what's up chris thanks for calling in
brother and chris is a name short for
christmas
short for what else
uh
galaxy no
i don't know what else let's hear more
riley kansas but um
i'm getting out of the army i'm going
back home to good old [ __ ] palmdale
california
palmdale ca i did a comedy show up there
one time and almost got abused actually
in a parking lot up there
onward
um it's kind of a bittersweet feeling
but
i don't know man i feel like i failed a
lot in my army career and
the career that i've had a chance in
before the army i was supposed to be
a part of you know the music industry
all this [ __ ] and i pissed it all away
because you know bad habits and drugs
and thinking i was mr [ __ ] know it
all
but
i don't know what what what kind of
i don't know i i'm kind of asking like
what what do you do
to make yourself make make yourself feel
like not like a failure i guess you
could say like
i'm just struggling struggling man
because every everywhere i turn i feel
like i [ __ ] it up i feel like i
never get anything right man so
a little bit of advice would help man
uh thanks for the call man um
and i'm sorry that you're feeling like
that i want to let you know right off
the bat you have
you know you sound like a confident
young man uh you sound like you got a
good voice on your strong throat
um
you're able to speak you know you have
i just want to remind you you're calling
because you care about yourself you're
trying to take action uh so those are
all really cool things you're doing for
yourself man
so
a failure doesn't do any of that well
for myself i you know sometimes my own
perception i can't rely on it because my
perception is too harsh on me my
perception doesn't remember the wins
that i do
uh my perception chooses to um
not make me the hero sometimes
and i don't mean in an egotistical way
it chooses to not uh
give me the benefit of the doubt
um
you know sometimes i treat myself in
ways that i would never treat somebody
else
uh
so that so so so i have to then ask
other people i have to get people around
me that i trust
and ask them you know what what do you
think is going on here uh am i okay am i
am i a failure
you know and i have to take their word
for it
um
and i have to and if i trust those
people and take their word and i believe
them believe that they care about me
then i know that they would tell me the
truth and uh
so sometimes i'm
my own
is
as
as much of a bummer as it is to say
my
own
perception is not the best place for me
to get a judgment of myself
i think we live in a time in an
environment where
we
don't know the effects of seeing so much
of ourselves all the time and of how
much of
we are
getting our perception from the outside
instead of the inside
where it used to come from
um which i think was a much healthier
place
um
and as far as uh being a failure man
i'll tell you what a failure somebody
doesn't try
you know i know i mentioned that but a
failure a failure isn't somebody that's
trying to figure out what's going on
with themselves
you know i feel like i feel like a
failure all the time man i compare
myself to my friends i look at certain
things i look at what you know this
isn't perfect this is i'm a failure
man i'm a failure
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
you know why can't you do things right
why can't and
the truth is some of that that voice
isn't really mine man
that's not a good
that's not a good
it's not safe for me to really even
listen to that voice inside of me
um
because yeah failure doesn't try
you know if failure doesn't try man
and so i know that by by even make
you're trying to see what's going on
you're trying
so those things didn't work out that's
okay
but now if we don't learn from those
things and that's where we start to see
patterns where it's like man
i'm not a failure but i am a repeater
now that's one thing i look i'll be a
dang repeater dog
you know i'll piss in my own milkshake a
lot of times
and i'll sit there and swing on it and
pretend i didn't man but after a while i
got to realize
that some of this urine taste
is because of me
so
you know you might be making some
missteps here or there but you also
might just be making some steps
you know a step isn't always
a step is always positive but it's not
always forward you know it could be
you know i don't know
i'm just saying man that you're trying
bro
and failures don't try and you're
learning things you're going to take
these pieces of what you've learned
you might take a piece of the military
and a piece of music you know you might
build a machine gun that shoots uh songs
at people
you know and just hit somebody with a
damn uh
you know you may hit somebody with a
damn um first class you know
you might damn just you know do a
drive-by at a uh
at a um
you know somewhere and ever next you
know everybody's singing uh
uh
aerosmith
you know i'm saying you might invent
something that you don't you just don't
know what the pieces that you are doing
what those are going to be used for
so
i don't think you're failing man i think
you're learning though i hope you are
you know and i think you're training
for
whatever the best you is gonna be
and uh i know it's hard man
i know it's hard
you know
um
but just don't feel like you're alone
and uh
and just don't give up man
and if nothing changes nothing changes
you gotta remember that
you know and uh
for myself you know i get back in a
12-step i you know i've recently really
leaned back into my recovery program and
um
there's even little moments during this
podcast where i feel more like myself
than i have in years
and uh
and yeah i got therapy today i'm gonna
talk to my sponsor later today
i'm putting things in place for me that
i know are gonna help me have a better
future that are gonna help me take care
of myself and i don't even want to
really
sometimes you know the craziest thing is
sometimes i don't even want to take care
of myself
there's a part of me that doesn't even
want to take care of me
um
[Music]
because i think some of that part of me
is just like oh
this was somebody else's job a long time
ago and they never did it and not why do
i have to still be doing this job
you know um
but i can't let that part of me win
uh
not today anyway
so
but look man i love you bro and i'm
proud of you and thank you for your
service dude thank you for going and
trying you know how many times i sit
around regretting that i didn't even try
you might be able to go back in
sometimes you know
[ __ ] just put on some high boots and
listen to two episodes of jocko bruh you
know what i'm saying you're not in the
military but you [ __ ] you'll scale
your neighbor's fence and attack that
bastard at a barbecue i know that [ __ ]
bro that [ __ ] will get you dialed up son
but um thank you guys for being a part
of my life we're looking for some new
jobs we want to have people call in to
do we know any of those what are some of
those uh
that we were looking at if you know
someone who is a unique personality that
does cornering
somebody that does corner core
coronering
dealing with the death right there
that last little guy that this that that
fellow that tickles you at the finish
line if you know somebody that does that
and has a unique personality
and uh yeah if there's a retired
homicide detective we'd like to speak
with one
um
somebody that's amish done full amish or
par we want full i don't want no fake
amish in here you know what i'm saying
uh we want full amish or mennonite
and we also looking for somebody uh
that um
[Music]
has
somebody who has been a long time
employee a 7-eleven employee we're
looking for
in a uh
in a unique area we want somebody that's
really been through the [ __ ]
and those people can email in the
producer email what is it
tpw producer at gmail
tpw producer at gmail if you have
somebody to recommend uh for those
things
um
and what should they send in what's the
best way for them to send something how
do they
uh i would uh i would put something in
the uh title line that stands out maybe
the name of your job
um and then just put location uh contact
years of experience and anything else
that you might want to add
okay great yeah and if you're
recommending someone you could also get
a video of them or something and send it
in there to the email um
but look man i love you guys thank you
guys for being a part of my life uh
we're gonna go out the same way we came
in you know i like this music just kind
of fit me feel lifted up
and this is uh there is a light by the
stone keepers
we had a lot of great calls we'll get to
some of them next time as well
if you haven't checked out the
trauma restoration man
go get a inkling of him um
if you know another good trauma
restoration man who's really been
through some unique things you might be
able to submit them as well
but check that episode we got tim dillon
coming up soon and
uh looking forward to a lot of great
guests
but uh
you guys also hit the hotline let me
know what job you do what do you do
where do you listen to the episode at
just put that in the voicemail 985 664
um
y'all keep my stepdad in your prayers
this week he's going in for surgery and
uh
and um
and i'm keeping him in mind you guys be
good to yourselves baby and uh love you
guys gang
[Music]
so
[Music]
you deserve it baby
[Music]
this is
there is a light by stonekeepers and
david manuel manuel manuel
manuel
[Music]
galaxy
[Music]
come on baby
[Music]
let's do it baby
there is a light
shining for you
guys
[Music]
we can be free
from the mountaintop
[Music]